tibet voulait savoir si je crois à ses
excuses je vous réponds non je pense que
il a d'abord il a été lui aussi
violemment insulté sur les réseaux
sociaux si j'ai bien compris
d'ailleurs je remarque que dans cette
histoire c'est les réseaux sociaux qui
font tout vous avez remarqué les médias
traditionnels n'en parle pas les réseaux
sociaux font l'allèle une réalité que
c'est très intéressant quand on les
critique tout le temps deuxièmement ses
excuses je pense que c'est c'est du
bidon
je pense que c'est un avocat de gauche
qui lui a conseillé de faire ça parce
que il a bien vu surtout les crachats
entend de coronavirus ça peut ça peut
aller chercher loin
alors eric zemmour qui pouvait penser de
la réponse d'eric eric naulleau est ce
que ce que je faisais procès de la
réponse d'eric zemmour c'était le
là-dessus ce qu'il ne fallait pas
financer j'expédie rapidement la
question des excuses parce que là je
suis entièrement d'accord avec eric
zémour c'est complètement bidon ce ce
pauvre type i said on essaye d'échapper
à deux choses l'accusation
d'antisémitisme et 10g pas agi couple
une communauté et puis il essaye
d'échapper un autre truc auquel on pense
pas c'est vrai que par temps d'épidémie
cracher sur quelqu'un ça peut être
considéré même comme du terrorisme
voilà j'expédie ça après il ya une chose
qui me dérange mais ça me dérangera
toujours chez ces examens je le
comprenais chaque semaine je combats
c'est que je tout s'inscrit dans un
système de pensée préalable c'est un
idéologue
je ne partage pas son idéologie mais en
même temps je suis je vais dit la
dernière fois que nous avons débattu de
ce sujet je suis horripilé je suis
exaspéré par le déni des gens qui ne
veulent pas voir qu'il ya un problème
avec une frange de la population vous ne
vais pas le mot racaille je l'utiliserai
pas ce soir une franche délinquante qui
se croient tout permis qui pensent
qu'elle peut agresser les gens ils sont
vantés sur les réseaux sociaux
donc je suis entre eux le rejet du déni
et le rejet des de certaines thèses
d'eric zemmour pourquoi dit-il un avocat
de gauche maintenant
d'après l'avocat aurait conseillé à ce
type de 10 par action
pourquoi parler d'islam aux racailles
l'islam a pas grand chose à voir dans
cette histoire il serait donnée pas du
prophète dont vous voyez je suis entre
les deux j'essaye d'être un homme
raisonnable par les temps qui courent
c'est très difficile